as lockdown restrictions begin to ease
care homes across the country are trying
to find a balance between keeping their
residents safe
and reintroducing visits from family
members and
loved ones anna selby is the director of
operations at
sunrise senior living uk and graceful
healthcare's covert 19 task force
she joins us from buckingham and bob
skinner as a resident
at sunrise of cardiff care home welcome
to
you both and achieve first of all um
what has it been
like running care homes during the the
pandemic explain for us
what you've had to go through yeah so it
well it's been a year
of um of lots of changes and lots of
adjustments we've had to
to really think through a lot of
problems and and find ways of
maintaining
safety in our homes and supporting our
residents to still
have um a quality of life so it's it's
been challenging but it's also been um
you know we recognize that we're able to
still give people that quality of life
and still keep them connected and
they're just the way that we work
um and that's kind of where i'm coming
to with this today is that we
we've had to be agile our residents have
been so resilient and
and brave and have um coped with all
kinds of things all kinds of changes
and and i feel that as we get to this
stage of the pandemic
there's another change to get to get
over and we've got to we've got to get
ready
for for coming out of conflict and and
we've got to maintain
as you say that balance of keeping
people safe but giving them
um what they deserve in their life in
what could be
you know the last couple of years of
somebody's life
and has it been difficult to explaining
to some of your residents exactly
you know what what's been going on for
the past year
i think um i mean no even people have
understood that they've what they've had
to i think it's the length of time and
i'm sure bob will talk about this i
think it's the length of time that this
has gone on i don't know if we knew a
year ago
where we'd be today so i think um
i don't think it's come as a surprise at
this point that that um
you know we've had to take the measures
that we've had to because we've
there's a there's a really deadly virus
out there that's particularly dangerous
for this
this age group um but i think that um
yeah our residents have adjusted as
they've coped they've you know they're
very resilient people they've
they've talked about how they felt
they've shared with us so one of the
most important things for us in terms of
our um planning through this has been
listening to people listening to our
residents listening to our family
members particularly
who can explain the things that we don't
necessarily see so that we can address
how people are feeling inside as well as
keeping them safe from the infection
that's raging
outside bob i wonder if you can explain
for us uh what it's been like for you
for the last year
well it's been a miserable year for
everyone um
dark in fact twists and turns
uh ups and downs you've never known from
one week to another
what's going to happen uh we've had our
hopes
raised and dashed as i say but we've
come through it
and the news now is the magnificent i
think
um the best for months to be able to see
our families
to have our families here after all
these months
is great um i spent a month in hospital
luckily i recovered
uh and since i haven't had a visitor for
about six months uh but tomorrow one of
my granddaughters
is coming and that's the end of it now
it's getting better
we're delighted and it's i'm so pleased
for
all the all the people here the staff
the carers at cardiff sunrise have been
absolutely brilliant from day one
it's been a long terrible year but the
it's getting better and we've got good
reason to be cheerful
um i don't know if you remember if you
used to be on holiday we'd send
postcards wish you were here
well that's what we've been doing all
the year wishing
our families we're here but we've been
lucky
because we've got email uh we've got
zoom today i'm speaking to my son later
today
so it's made a big difference but i
realized that
there are so many elderly people
especially the ones with
mental troubles or um alzheimer's
who've had to struggle but they've been
helped through it
and because the carers and the help
we've all had
it's good to see daylight coming again
it won't be very long i'm sure before
we all get back to a normal life which
will be so much better after all we've
been through
no no one's have no one's sad we are
looked after we're happy
and all together i can't say other than
i'm happy to be here
well bob i tell you what you've
certainly cheered uh my spirits what a
positive
outlook i mean that's one of the the
most positive um
summaries of of what we've been through
and what we should be looking ahead to
uh and anna i mean hearing from bob
there
really that there is light at the end of
the tunnel we're almost there aren't we
yes we're almost there i mean we we have
to be careful still you know we
we're not out of the woods yet but that
we should be working our way out of the
woods and we should be as positive
as bob is around what we can do next and
get ready for the next stage get ready
to adjust
and really show um the world that living
in a care home is
is good for people that people can come
out of this and resume their life as it
was
and i think um you know a lot of people
have been
shielded and isolated and lonely at home
uh you know
in our homes people haven't been alone
so and we're in a really fortunate
position that we can support that
change again this time around so that
we're facing the world and that people
have really connecting with like bob
says with people that they haven't seen
for a long time
and uh it's it's a wonderful it's
wonderful we just have to make sure
people aren't overwhelmed that people
can adjust but it's a wonderful
position to be in to know that we're
going to be able to start connecting
people in a meaningful way again very
soon
and bob just finally to you what are you
most looking forward to
uh we're looking ahead we're steaming
ahead
it's going to be happy days ahead in
fact i've got a
first visit for six months my gran one
of my granddaughters ria
is coming tomorrow afternoon i couldn't
be happier
happy days ahead for you there bob thank
you so much for speaking to us bob and
anna
you